réformer tout la police française en
quatre mois des changes
voici les objectifs ambitieux du beauvau
de la sécurité avec d'abord la question
de la loi loppsi loi de programmation
budgétaire et les conditions d'exercice
des policiers au coeur du débat
puis en toile de fond cette question
cruciale celle des violences policières
depuis les nombreux blessés dans les
manifestations des gilets jaunes et de
nouveaux premier plan avec la sphère
michel est clair des violences dénoncé à
plusieurs reprises lors des
mobilisations sociales qui se sont
multipliées depuis le début du mandat d'
emmanuel macron une contestation qui
s'est récemment accentué à l'occasion
des manifestations contre le projet de
loi sécurité globale et son article 24
censée protéger les forces de l'ordre en
contrôlant la diffusion malveillantes
d'image des policiers pourtant les liens
police population ne sont pas l'objectif
prioritaire et ne feront l'objet que
d'une seule table ronde sur quatre mois
de travaux le dialogue s'annonce
difficile entre les forces de l'ordre et
le chef de l'état ces derniers ont
vivement critiqué les manoeuvres des
manuels macron on n'a pas besoin d'un
énième séminaire on sort tout juste d'un
livre blanc sur la sécurité et on veut
nous refaire le coup
le président a eu quelques paroles
malheureuses il se dit je vais faire ça
et acheter la paix sociale
mais c'est une hanche human politique
des policiers qui ont eux-mêmes
manifesté à plusieurs reprises en 2020
avec des rassemblements symboliques
notamment sur les champs elysées le
dernier en date remonte à décembre 2020
une mobilisation suite à une interview
du président sur le média brut dans
laquelle des membres des forces de
l'ordre se sont sentis abandonnés au
mois de juin
certains d'entre eux se sentait déjà
lâché par l'ancien ministre de
l'intérieur christophe castaner la
formation des policiers
régulièrement pointée du doigt par les
experts et une partie de l'opinion
publique en novembre 2020
gérald darmanin reconnaissait lui-même
des carences dans le domaine il y à une
erreur fondamentale que nous avons
commises au ministère de l'intérieur
c'est le peu de formation que nous
offrons à nos policiers raccourcir la
formation initiale c'est à dire quand on
embauche un policier n'était pas une
bonne mesure
d'après le ministre de l'intérieur cet
ennui proposition très fortes devraient
aboutir à l'issue des discussions de ce
beau mot de la sécurité des idées qui
seront ensuite soumises à emmanuel
macron pour tenter de pacifier les
rapports entre les forces de l'ordre et
la population comme annoncé dans le
programme et à travers un tweet de
gérald darmanin les tables rondes seront
diffusés en direct sur internet
une manière pour le gouvernement
d'affirmer une volonté de transparence